Traduttore: Cristiano Montalbano
Revisore: Michele Gianella
All'inizio fu il Verbo.
Il Verbo, la parola.
Sono le parole che cambiano
il nostro mondo,
la realtà in cui abitiamo.
Hanno questo potere.
Porto un esempio:
al sei percento dei ragazzi
sotto i 18 anni
oggi viene diagnosticato
il disturbo attentivo e l'iperattività:
una scatola stretta dove incasellare
quello che non è conforme.
E non ci sono dubbi che,
se fossi nata adesso,
sarei sicuramente
stata certificata al Meyer.
Non al Meyer, alla Stella Maris;
il centro locale
per questo tipo di disturbi.
Mia mamma, invece di farmi fare
strane diagnosi, risolveva tutto:
prima, dandomi un paio di scappellotti;
e poi dicendo che avevo
"l'argento vivo addosso".
E sentite già così
quanta libertà, invece, lascia.
Il modo con cui chiamiamo
le cose le cambia.
Le parole o danno o tolgono,
non sono mai neutre.
Il disturbo, non ci sono dubbi,
toglie; l'argento vivo da.
All’inizio fu il verbo, la parola.
La mia era "argento vivo".
Infatti a me questo argento
ha dato tantissimo.
Ha dato l'opportunità
di occuparmi di 100 cose,
mettere il naso in diecimila
e farne un milione
E non ultimo, di crescere
sulla punta delle dita
due coppie di gemelli nate in due anni.
Due coppie di gemelli nati in due anni.
(Applausi)
Il modo con cui chiamiamo
le cose le cambia.
Qualcuno l'ha chiamata una catastrofe.
Per me è stato il dono
che ha cambiato la mia vita
e mi ha insegnato un paio di cose,
lasciatemele condividere.
Fino a quel momento,
la mia storia era una storia come tante:
lo studio, l'Università,
gli amici, le feste;
e poi l'amore,
il fidanzamento, il matrimonio.
E poi, come nelle
migliori tradizioni, la gravidanza
"E tutti vissero felici e contenti".
Invece no.
Qui la cosa inizia ad annodarsi.
Il primo nodo sono due gemelli,
e le prime informazioni
che ricevo dagli operatori,
tipo il ginecologo,
l'ostetrica e il pediatra
sono che: i gemelli non nascono
quasi mai naturalmente;
ma soprattutto che i gemelli
non si possono allattare.
O meglio: si possono allattare,
ma nessuno l'ha mai visto fare.
Il mondo definito,
per me, da qualcun altro.
Un'altra scatola,
un limite oltre il quale
sembra impossibile spingersi.
Questo verbo però,
andava in contrapposizione
con quello che diceva la mia nonna Gilda,
ormai novantenne.
Borbottava sempre di qualcosa di donne
che ai suoi tempi,
con una manciata di fagioli,
riuscivano a prendere a balia
e allattare una schiera di ragazzetti
che noi donne moderne,
cresciute con le bistecche,
non saremmo in grado di farlo
neanche per un bambino solo.
Il verbo di nonna Gilda, dentro di me,
a creare la mia realtà,
ad aiutarmi a vedere
oltre la scatola, oltre l'orizzonte.
Io infatti vado avanti:
si sa, sono un’iperattiva -
o meglio, ho l'"argento vivo" addosso.
E quindi lavoro, faccio, brigo, forco,
mi sento in forze, sto benissimo.
La mia gravidanza è una "groovydance",
dico tutta soddisfatta.
Ecco però il secondo nodo.
Uno dei cuccioli ha una malformazione,
e deve essere operato appena nato.
La cosa è grave, e le parole, il verbo,
dicono che il 50 percento
dei nati con questa malformazione
non ce la fa:
Terzo nodo:
quella che fino a quel momento
sentivamo come una bella cosa
diventa invece un ulteriore ostacolo.
I gemelli nascono prima,
e quindi più piccoli;
e questo può mettere
ulteriore aggravio sull'operazione.
Questa nuova storia,
questa narrativa mi sovrasta,
e la mia groovydance
diventa una grave danza.
L'attesa si fa opprimente
e insopportabile.
Mi metterò a casa,
buona buona, a fare niente.
Ma ormai si sa che ferma non ci sto,
e quindi inizio a leggere,
studiare, conoscere, sapere.
Informarmi e sapere
diventa la mia nuova ancora,
il mio modo di trovare altre parole,
di creare ancora un mondo nuovo per me.
Non vi trattengo
sui dettagli dell'operazione,
o del mese passato al Meyer;
ma oggi, Cosimo è così.
Quindi -
(Applausi)
Non si fa, che poi piango.
Quindi, tutto è andato alla grande
e lui ha incrementato
la casistica dei casi risolti.
Ma quello che mi è successo
mentre eravamo in ospedale
è la storia che vi voglio raccontare.
La più grande trasformazione
del mio mondo,
la fase della vita in cui ho imparato
l'importanza di non voler fermare
il vento con le mani.
Subito, appena nato,
è arrivato qualcuno
che mi ha chiesto se avrei allattato.
Io ero molto confusa e non lo sapevo.
Mi ha precisato, però,
che se non lo avessi fatto,
vista la situazione molto delicata,
avrei dovuto rimediare con dieci
fra integratori e medicinali vari.
Ma a me le doppie pesate,
i biberon, il latte formulato
mi davano un'idea
di pesantezza, di fatica.
Come avere il vento in poppa
e invece andare a remi.
Un giorno, però, finalmente a casa,
mi sono seduta con i miei neonati
sul mio divano comodo.
Ho portato cose da mangiare, cose da bere,
musica, libri, telecomandi, tablet
e tutto quello che pensavo
mi sarebbe servito da lì a un anno.
Mi sono acciambellata, come in una cuccia,
e ho attaccato i miei bimbi al seno.
Mio marito diceva che ci puzzava
come dentro una tana di una volpe.
Però ho detto a tutti
che avevo finalmente capito
a cosa serve una mamma,
e cioè allattare
e nutrire i propri cuccioli.
E che, da quel giorno, chiunque
mi avrebbe trovato lì, spiaggiata.
La sensazione di leggerezza che ho provato
è stata deflagrante e spaventosa.
Essere sospinti dal vento
senza opporre resistenza.
Ho fatto purtroppo tanti errori.
Cose sciocche che un minimo
di esperienza avrebbe evitato.
Un passo avanti e due indietro, come ora.
Ma nessuno sapeva aiutarmi.
Ho combattuto contro
ignoranza, pressapochismo,
modi di dire, luoghi comuni,
paure e ansie.
Anche chi mi sosteneva
non sapeva che dirmi.
Perché i gemelli
si possono anche allattare,
ma chi lo ha mai visto fare?
Un po’ matta, o fricchettona,
o antica o fissata.
Perfino "talebana",
mi sono sentita apostrofare.
Le parole.. eppure,
nessuna di queste mi offendeva.
La mia storia di latte
è stata una storia bellissima
e perfettamente riuscita.
Ancora di più, poi,
con la seconda coppia di gemelle
dove potevo finalmente applicare
tutto quello che avevo imparato.
A quel punto, però,
ho sentito un'emozione nuova.
Ho sentito come fondamentale,
addirittura urgente,
riuscire a trasferire quello
che avevo imparato sulla mia pelle
per aiutare più mamme possibile
a riuscire, visto che nessuno lo fa.
Mi sentivo un po‘ così:
il mondo va a fuoco,
e io solo posso spegnerlo.
Non c'è tempo da perdere.
Quindi, visto che sono un’iperattiva,
ho cominciato a studiare
e sono diventata
consulente d'allattamento.
E ho lavorato nei distretti
e ho lavorato negli ospedali.
Però, purtroppo, si sa come funziona:
i soldi per i nuovi corsi non ci sono;
le Usl - o ASL, come si
chiamano ora, non investono;
e tutto diventa un po’ difficile.
E così abbiamo dovuto mollare.
Tempo fa, Umberto Eco
ricevette il plauso unanime
perché disse che Facebook
ha dato a tutti i cretini
l'opportunità di parlare
a un pubblico vasto.
Ora, io non sono nessuno
per contraddire il grande e compianto Eco:
ma uno strumento è uno strumento,
dipende che uso ne fai.
Con un coltello
si può uccidere una persona,
o sbucciare una mela.
A me che ho l'argento vivo
addosso, invece,
Facebook ha dato l'occasione
di guardare davvero
oltre l'orizzonte del possibile.
Di raggiungere il sogno
di cambiare il mondo.
Ho creato un gruppo:
“allattamento materno gemellare”;
Ma oggi, 1700 mamme gemellari,
da tutt'Italia e anche
da varie parti del mondo,
allatta due o più gemelli
anche grazie al mio supporto
e a quello delle meravigliose
moderatrici del gruppo -
questo è il gruppo:
"Allattamento materno gemellare".
Allatto due o più gemelli, dicevo,
anche grazie al supporto mio
e quello delle mie meravigliose
moderatrici del gruppo
che ogni giorno - eccole qua -
che ogni giorno e ogni ora aiutano,
rispondono ai dubbi, e alle paure,
e alle ansie e allo sconforto
di queste mamme che si sentono così sole.
Creando una rete di solidarietà,
sostegno e di amore.
Ogni cosa può diventare un'opportunità.
Anche quella che inizia con tanti nodi.
Datevi sempre l'opportunità
di credere, di crescere, di aiutare.
All'inizio fu il Verbo:
la mia parola, oggi, è evoluzione.
Grazie.
(Applausi)